Jason Alexander is unquestionably best known
for one role, but what a role it was: high-strung
lucky loser George Costanza on Seinfeld.
He was just 29 when the show premiered in
1989.
Playing an iconic character early in one's
career can be a double-edged sword.
Sure, the job security, money, and being a
part of TV history are nice, but it's hard
for an audience to accept actors in other
roles after they're so closely associated
with one familiar character.
Believe it or not, Alexander has had a colorful,
balanced, and sometimes glamorous career after
Seinfeld.
Here's what he's been up to recently.
Cursed to fail
For years, there was talk of a "Seinfeld Curse,"
which seemed to affect the former cast of
that classic comedy.
Everyone's first post-Seinfeld projects tanked:
Julia Louis-Dreyfus' Watching Ellie, Michael
Richards' The Michael Richards Show, and a
pair of Jason Alexander shows.
First up was Bob Patterson, a short-lived
2000 ABC sitcom about a motivational speaker
whose personal life was a mess.
"To my colleague, Bob Patterson, who is a
constant reminder that there is more to life
than success."
Then came Listen Up, which followed a fictionalized
version of sports radio host Tony Kornheiser,
who's a big shot at work but has a dysfunctional
personal life.
Both shows lasted less than a year.
Taking charge
Few people know episodic TV better than Jason
Alexander.
Seinfeld featured more complicated direction
than most traditional sitcoms in the '90s.
Thus, Alexander's experience on that show
makes him uniquely qualified to direct television,
and that's what he does now.
He's helmed episodes of everything from the
improv-heavy Campus Ladies to the single-camera
Everybody Hates Chris to tried-and-true sitcom
fare like Mike & Molly, and even dramas like
Criminal Minds.
He also directed and appeared in country star
Brad Paisley's music video for the hit song
"Online."
Song-and-dance Man
Before Seinfeld premiered, Alexander was a
theater guy.
In the '80s, he starred in plenty of New York
stage fare, including Jerome Robbins' Broadway,
which earned him a Tony Award for best actor
in a musical.
After Seinfeld concluded in 1998, he returned
to the footlights, starring as Max Bialystock
in the first national tour of The Producers.
He also notably had a starring role in the
2015 play Fish in the Dark, which was written
by Seinfeld co-creator Larry David.
"If I came to see the play, would you want
me to come backstage?"
"Uh...you would not have to come backstage,
heres-"
"That's all I needed to hear!"
On the road, on stage
Like other well-known comic actors that came
before him, Alexander hit the stage with an
autobiographical one-person show, entitled
An Evening with Jason Alexander and His Hair.
Described as a "hilarious re-telling of his
journey to and on the Broadway stage," Alexander
sings songs, tells jokes, and does a little
crowd work.
He also wears a "completely bogus" hair piece
for the performance.
He's toured the show off and on in casinos
and theaters around the world since 2014.
On the road, on TV
There are so many networks cranking out high
quality TV these days that it's easy to overlook
even a show starring a Seinfeld veteran.
Since the fall of 2017, Alexander has starred
on the Audience Network's Hit the Road, which
he co-created.
He plays a dad in search of higher meaning
in his life who forces his family into a rock
band-style tour bus to drive around the country.
"Let's go!
Suit up and start zazzing, start zazzing,
suit it up!
Suit it up!"
The Israeli-Palestinian conflict
Alexander was raised in a Jewish home, and
he has worked extensively with a group aiming
to broker understanding in Israel.
In 2004, he helped launch the "One Voice"
campaign, which enabled regular Palestinians
and Israelis living in disputed areas to vote
online for peace and settlement initiatives.
Alexander's work with the campaign has included
public appearances and promotional videos.
"Peace.
Together.
Now."
Too rich to work too hard
Alexander hit the showbiz jackpot with Seinfeld.
Not only was it a creatively fulfilling role
on a hit sitcom for which he earned multiple
Emmy nominations and lasting fame, but he
was also handsomely paid.
In the final season alone, he earned $600,000
an episode.
Factoring in his cut from endless reruns on
syndication and online streaming, Alexander
is reportedly worth millions today.
If we don't see him on screens too much anymore,
perhaps it's because he can afford to be selective
with his time.
"Well, the jerk store called, they're running
out of you!"
"What's the difference, you're their all time
best seller!"